hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
just wanted to say Happy Thanksgiving to
all you all and instead of just doing a
regular video today I wanted to do
something very different very special
and something a lot more personal in my
mind I'm gonna tell you about all the
drama going on with it now I want this
to be a very positive inducing video I'm
gonna encourage you guys to share things
that you'll be grateful for as well
considering that it's Thanksgiving it's
a time to give thanks a time to also
remember how we got America which is a
beautiful story in a very positive adieu
single doing great on the positive side
of this video what I wanted to share
with you guys today something I do in my
personal life every single day for you
guys who might be new or never happy to
hear me ever talk about it before I used
to be on a lot of medication used to go
to therapy weekly I still go to therapy
but not as consistently every every
single week but I do a lot to take care
of myself so I usually have like like
right here I have a big to-do list and I
mean simply can't see because white on
camera but right now I have 11 things
listed on here and usually there's three
things out of whatever tasks I have
every day that I list that I have to do
just for myself to maintain a calm life
and a positive outlook on life one of
them is meditation which I do for only
about 10 to 15 minutes there's a great
app for that by the way called headspace
really taught me the benefits of
meditation and when I started
implementing it it really helped out
especially helped when I was getting off
my meds last year around I'd say March
of last year March or April of last year
the other thing I do is I journal I
journal for about 20 to 30 minutes a day
sometimes I miss it but I'd say on
average six to seven days a week I
accomplish both meditating and
journaling the journaling I do a stream
of consciousness journaling meaning I
just do three straight pages of
whatever's on my mind whatever's coming
in my mind whatever's coming to my heart
and I just keep going at it and - until
I accomplished three direct pages
sometimes I go on four more if I got a
lot going on I tend to have a lot of
thoughts and have a lot of feelings so I
just do a lot of that I also exercise
about four to five times a week now
average even though the past few days
has been a lot of friends givings a lot
of parties so I'm pretty bloated right
now exercising especially this year has
been incredibly beneficial for me I
start off meditating and I implemented
exercising and then I do journaling and
I usually do therapy about once a month
right now but these are all things that
help keep my mind clear and in check and
allow me to be comfortable in front of
the camera be comfortable when I'm
interacting with people be present you
know it's easy to get worried about the
future or caught up in you know drama or
traumas of the past or whatever a lot of
times we have a hard time just being
present and these things really help me
and the other thing I do which is what
the main theme of today's video is of
attitude of gratitude after I meditate I
usually take time to say things I am
grateful for and of course it's better
if you can live a life where throughout
the day you are constantly saying what
you're grateful for sure if you guys
have read the secret or seen that
documentary to read other books the
power of positive thinking what not that
stuff really does help out with knowing
the benefits of being grateful knowing
the benefits love loving yourself and
loving others and loving what you have a
phrase I heard many years ago be
grateful for what you have while you are
in pursuit of what you want I've heard
that from a motivational personal
development speaker named Jim Rohn my
fav my favorite Jim Rohn that's how he
has this weird way of talking he's
passed on a few years ago but I still
listen to his audio quite often what I
wanted to share with you guys is you
know some tips on how to just be more
grateful for everything in life and
really having a grateful attitude really
helps out before filming this video
today I was feeling in a funk I woke up
this morning like 6:30 in the morning
had a big migraine and I was feeling
really nauseous so I you know if I've
edited and whatever and then I
eventually went back to sleep sleep off
the headache but this feeling off my
game so I exercised i journaled and I
meditated and then I said 20 things I'm
grateful for and now I'm here and that's
where I got the inspiration and do this
video for a special Thanksgiving video I
usually have a few go to things that I
say I'm grateful for I like to say
things I'm grateful for in relation that
I have or people I'd know specifically
and then I like to say ten things I'm
grateful for about myself now sharing
that makes me cringe you look good
talking about me at all who cares what I
usually start off with I say ten things
and I usually say I'm grateful for my
mother Joyce you can spitball these if
you want but you know since I'm doing a
video I might as well share a little bit
more detail I'm grateful for my mother
Joyce she's been through some really
really tough times in her years yet
she's always been a very strong mother
for me and has taught me a lot about
being a hard worker and not giving up
and the value of family I'm grateful for
my brother Anthony Jabby Co Al I'm very
grateful for him you know we've helped
each other a lot through the years of
especially of doing YouTube and growing
up we might not have been like super
close but in the past few years we've
gotten a lot closer to this day always
there for me if I really need him my
sister Megan she's just the best sister
you can ask for she's so into movies and
she's such a good artist I feel like
she's a million times more intellectual
than me over there where we shoot our
movie reviews about you know the posters
over there the paintings she she
actually drew all those and she knew
another one over here
she can't see all the t-shirt designs
most of them are drawn by her she
constantly gives me a bunch of artwork
as well I'm grateful for these are the
things I usually second I am grateful
for my best friend John my brother my
partner in crime
hey John John's on the couch right now
taking care of some emails hey John I'm
grateful for you buddy
I love you you're my best friend he's my
partner known for 20 years
fantastic human being I am grateful for
my girlfriend if you follow me on
instagram you'll know her name choose to
keep that more private now but I'm very
grateful for her always laugh together
I'm grateful for my phone I tend to
mention that too not grateful that it's
going off in the middle this video but I
am grateful for it yeah I'm really
grateful for my girlfriend she makes me
laugh like no other woman ever has and
we just have the same exact sense of
humor and she's so caring if somebody
this similar interest on things and we
could talk about anything yeah I just
had the best [ __ ] time in the world
that woman and she's great I miss even a
little bit I am grateful for you guys
YouTube I'm grateful for I say it every
time I'm doing my gratitude affirmations
I'm grateful for the real rejects the
whole umbrella
I'm grateful the FIR the views the video
still get despite algorithm despite at
apocalypse I'm grateful that you know
we're still able to make some bills with
YouTube and that it's the channel still
grows we passed 500 thousand subscribers
usually a few videos a week or a few
videos a month do really well and I'm
very grateful for any views that the
videos get if they could be small or
they could be big no matter what I'm
grateful that people are still watching
this channel I'm grateful that people
still get notified so I'm at least I'm
very grateful for everyone over at our
patreon man so many people have just
really shown their support I mean we
started during the apocalypse and we had
some reward tears and then over the
course of time it's become this much
more personal side of the real rejects
this is more like like the kind of video
that would probably go on our patreon so
many fantastic people over there who
have really shown a lot of love and I'm
so grateful that people would you know
it's like it's weird to talk about but
yeah people throw down money and we as
much as a big giver of war tears I'm so
grateful that people find it a value to
contribute to that degree so thank you
guys I'm grateful for this apartment I'm
grateful to have a place to live I'm
grateful to have place to live I always
advise that if you don't like where
you're living as I've lived in several
places that you didn't like living but I
would always do my best to say what I'm
grateful for about the apartment or
wherever I'm living it's easy to want
more it's easy to get caught up on lack
of I feel like if you are grateful for
what you currently have that usually
attracts more I'm grateful for my cats
Todd and copper who are usually making
cameos in the video I'm grateful for all
the clothes I have I have so many
clothes now so many clothes over the
years in YouTube and I'm grateful that I
have clothes to wear I am grateful for
whatever money is in my bank account at
any given moment sometimes it's in the
negative sometimes it's you know doing
well but whatever the current situation
is I'm glad I'm still able to stay
afloat and I'm grateful for whatever
money I ever earned grateful for the
sponsorship opportunities we've been
having I'm grateful for Stardust you
know like they it's that's the best
sponsorship partnership we've ever had
and truly I'm grateful to include them
in the community I'm grateful for all my
friends grateful for my electronics I'm
grateful for everyone who comes on this
channel and sometimes you know I know
that was about 10 things there's so much
to be grateful for like it's easy to
list when you think about it some people
have a hard time doing and in the
beginning when I was learning about this
I did have a hard time I really hurts in
the details really hurts in the details
you know if you say I'm grateful for my
all my friends or all my family it's
like you can make that more specific and
I can give me grateful of the camera cut
okay I'm grateful that you know when it
comes to breaking it down it's one
phrase I used to hear all the time break
it down you can break anything down and
you can go to your clothes and you know
look there you can look at what is
currently in front of you and say what
you're grateful for I'm grateful that we
have a nice camera to film on a lot of
people don't have a nice camera I'm
grateful for being able to afford this
mic to be able to get a mic extension to
make the audio better I'm grateful that
we have lights a lot of people don't get
to have these things it's easy to take
these things for credit and I'm grateful
for this computer that my brother
actually built that allows me to edit
and get videos up faster this is me just
looking around right now I'm grateful
for my hair it's on my hair and in the
view and the flip camera here they used
to hate my hair up until this year you
just hate it he's like Oh curly hair
it's impossible to manage but it's
different a lot of people don't have the
curls and I'm grateful that I have the
curls and then when I talk about me you
know and I when I list what I'm grateful
for about me which is usually the things
I don't share out loud to other people
but I'll do it right now I'm grateful
that I'm funny I think I'm a pretty
funny guy and if you don't think I'm
funny whatever being funny is a you know
subjective I'm grateful that I am
charismatic careful and charming I think
I am that's the thing is when you do it
out loud you feel like you gotta defend
yourself instead of when you're by
yourself you just believe I'm grateful
that I I'm unique I'm grateful I am I'm
wise I'm grateful I'm self-aware I'm
grateful I'm creative I'm grateful I'm
imaginative I am grateful I'm a I'm a
hard worker I'm grateful I don't quit
I'm grateful I'm not a quitter and I'm
really grateful for that and grateful
that I personal develop and I really
mean that I'm grateful that I work on
myself and I'm grateful that I
and pretty good communicator I'm
grateful that I'm good at connecting
with people I'm grateful that I am full
of love never felt like what I'm really
grateful for this year above all things
is this is the first year I've ever
actually felt like I love myself I used
to look for love from validation from
other people or the work I do or
whatever I always looked for other
things to validate myself and I'm pretty
cool guy and I'm okay with saying that
now and I think I'm a dude I'm a neat
guy there's never sort of friends Bruce
Lewis I'm a neat guy what I would
suggest you know when you're looking to
be grateful if you want to increase your
attitude of gratitude it's pretty simple
it's really simple it's all in the
details it really is all in the detail
it's the little things it's the littlest
thing people often go I'm grateful my
family I'm grateful my friends and
that's that's super important to be
grateful for but you can make it more
specific
yeah I'm grateful for a lot of my inner
core friends we have one for Andrew I'm
grateful for Tony I'm grateful for
Courtney I'm grateful for Ashlee I'm
grateful for Anita
she's great friend I'm grateful for Kyle
I'm grateful for every single guest so
many guests right now and the last time
I tried a naming guess off the top of my
head I was like so many I missed out
then I just felt terrible as much as I
would love to just list everyone right
now I'd be taking a long-ass time I have
plenty of friends I'm so grateful that I
have so many I'm great and if I look
around here being grateful for the
little things we're full but I have a
television I'm grateful for the DVDs I
have beautiful for the these paintings
that are hung above here I'm grateful
that I have food in the fridge you know
it's really feeling that and the more
grateful you are for things the more
likely are to attract more of that so
don't focus on lack of focus on what you
currently have it's that simple
it really is that simple and because I
could keep going I would remember once
out last year New Year's on the way to
roses party it was like I show John like
it's really easy to be grateful inside
sort of like spitballing say yeah no
matter how little it's those little
things that count the most so I'm
grateful for all you guys who are
watching this video being grateful is
the most important thing it's not just a
day
for Thanksgiving it's not just a day for
the holidays it's every day and some
days are much easier than others some
days are really rough and it's very hard
to be grateful but if you can get
yourself to that point it shifts your
mood and it shifts results in your life
overall so if you made it to the end of
the video why don't you put down in the
comments below what you find in life
that you are grateful for feel free to
be specific feel free to keep it a
little more vague if you want to be more
private whatever just share its
encourage some positivity YouTube
comments are known for being a dark
wormhole so let's increase some
positivity
happy Thanksgiving to all you beautiful
people out there